[Music]
why hello there
good citizens of the world i'm dave
rubin this is the reuben report direct
message for today april
9th april 9 2021
i just chugged coffee right before we
started it didn't fully get down
here we are don't forget to subscribe
and click that notification bell
i'm in a good mood we've got a bunch of
great stories today
little zany little depressing little
uplifting i'll try to give you every
emotion known to man in roughly 30
minutes
we're going to start with some of this
hunter biden stuff he was on jimmy
kimmel
last night i know nobody watches jimmy
kimmel anymore if you don't know who
jimmy kimmel is he's the blackface guy
that's on uh
i believe abc late night uh and he
interviewed hunter and it was just
absolutely ridiculous so we're gonna
play a little clip of that
then uh speaking of joe he uh
is gonna have male prisoners go to
female
jails yeah and he had said that he was
gonna do it months ago and everyone was
like nah he's not gonna do it but yeah
we're going to be sending
male trans prisoners into female prisons
if they so choose to go there that's
just
brilliant seemingly the next idiotic
thing on this crazy train
that we seem to be on these days then
the head of the cdc who we played a clip
of her last week uh with her fear of
impending doom
related to kovid as we seem to be
opening up everything and everyone's
kind of getting over covered we're just
like
okay no more coped that's it with the
covid uh she now
has another crisis that we have to worry
about that's even worse
than kovid and of course it starts with
an r and it ends with an m
and it's racism we'll talk about that
and then finally
you know everyone is always pushing this
idea of 15
minimum wage as if the government has
any right to tell companies how much
they should pay people
or how or that they should even be
involved in the market at that level
or it's just so bananas all together but
marriott is now testing out kiosks
basically
ipads to replace the people that would
normally be at the front desk which we
already know this is happening at
mcdonald's and a whole bunch of
other fast food places and it's just
such an obvious extension
when the government gets involved with
business business figures out a better
way they always figure out
a better mousetrap so we are going to
cover all of that and before i get
to any of that i want to talk to you
about raycon i've got my raycon earbuds
right here people and as you know once a
year i like to go off the grid for the
month of august i cannot wait
to do it this year but as you can
imagine unplugging is easier said than
done and what about the other
11 months of the year i still need my
time away from screens and devices
and fortunately by putting in my new
raycon
wireless earbuds i found a way to rest
my eyes without missing the important
content i need to do my job and live my
best life
whether you're catching up on reuben
report episodes spectacular show if you
haven't seen it
listening to the audiobook version of
don't burn this book great book if you
haven't read it or powering through your
workout with a pumped up playlist a pair
of rakons in your ears can make all
the difference i've been popping these
in while i'm walking clyde and i
i usually listen to music but podcasts
are good too
with no dangling wires or stems raycons
come in a range of stylish colorways
and always with a comfortable in-ear fit
for a more discreet look raycons are
built to perform
anywhere and anytime with water and
sweat resistant construction excuse me
and bluetooth that pairs quicklessly and
seamlessly
and with enough battery life for six
hours of playtime you can unplug for a
while
the best part ratecon makes great sound
accessible to everyone with wireless
earbuds
starting at half the price of other
premium audio brands raycon's offering
off all their products for my listeners
and here's what you got to do
to go grab them go to buy raycon dot com
slash ruben that's it you'll get 15
off your entire raycon order so feel
free to grab a pair
and a spare that's 15 off at buy raycon
dot com buy raycon dot com slash reuben
and now back to me all right guys so
hunter biden was on the jimmy kimmel
program
last night now jimmy kimmel is the late
night guy on abc he runs around he calls
everybody racist i'm pretty sure he
called ben shapiro racist
you know he's just one of these woke
people who used to host the man show
with my buddy adam carolla
and do all sorts of stuff related to
women but somehow he never got me
tooed or they haven't canceled him or
all the jokes by the way women jumping
up on
down on trampolines these were jokes
that were okay years ago now they're
things that should destroy careers
but one of the reasons i think a guy
like jimmy kimmel who's probably a
decent guy
the one of the reasons i think he's gone
so woke is because he knows
all of his history because it was the
man show stuff all the stuff he did
related to women
he was also famously in blackface doing
an impression of carl malone
and the way he speaks carmelo and
obviously a black former nba player utah
jazz
uh went to the nba finals in 96 and no
not 96 97 97 and 98
i got my facts down straight uh but
anyway
hunter biden went on jimmy kimmel's show
last night and before we show you the
clip
the really fascinating thing about this
is let's remember before the election
twitter banned banned
the story about hunter biden's laptop
from the entire platform and it was
taken off a bunch of the social media
sites
so meaning this laptop had showed up at
this store
the guy who took the laptop in realized
that it was hunter biden's they somehow
get it to the fbi
new york post runs a story on it which
they stand by but it was banned from
everything before the election so we
couldn't even talk about it
now it's sort of leaking out that yeah
it was his computer it was his hard
drive there's all sorts of
really whacked out pictures showing up
we're going to show you just one because
i don't want to
show you a whole bunch of them i mean
there's a bunch of nude pictures and
blah blah blah by the way i don't have a
problem with anyone doing whatever the
hell they want to do in the privacy of
their own home
this is more about the way the media
treated the story before the election we
weren't allowed to talk about hunter
biden because obviously that was going
to hurt
that you know the guy they wanted to be
president joe biden but now we can do
this reconstruction thing related
to hunter biden and he can you know talk
to
what was it cbs about snorting parmesan
cheese out of the carpet because that's
how desperate he was for drugs
and now that makes you know he's he's
the victim somehow and then he went on
jimmy kimmel last night and
just take a look does it make you crazy
when you hear someone like donald trump
jr
saying that the only reason he does is
because he's a biden
and uh because of his last name and how
just
wildly comical that is i mean does it it
is
wildly comical is that that's putting it
um uh lightly i think but
but you know i really what i've learned
is this
is that i don't spend too much time
thinking about it i do i think about it
all the time
i'll think about it for you well maybe
that's why because i have other people
to think about it for me
i have other people that think about it
do you know donald trump jr no
you've never met him no not that i know
of not that i know
man look at the reclamation project
they're doing on this guy now i believe
in second chances
we've all done bad things that we're not
proud of as hunter obviously has done
and hopefully he's cleaned himself up
and he's heading in the right direction
but but everything they're saying there
is complete nonsense the implication
that somehow don jr would be
you know skating by in essence if he was
found with crack
and hookers and all the pictures and the
laptop and the crazy text messages and
all that but somehow it's worse
because it's hunter biden as he's on a
pr tour
going through hollywood while they're
making him
look really real really great by the way
if you're noticing his
fancy smile there here's one of the
pictures that showed up on his laptop
this is
from smoking crack i guess it really
messes up your teeth now i'm not
i'm actually not making fun of him for
that so you can come back to me i don't
have to belabor the picture
it's not about or from smoking crack or
smoking meth or
whatever the hell it is he was doing i'm
not bringing that up but the point is
if that was donald trump's son and the
pictures were of
prostitutes and the teeth and the drugs
and he was talking about snorting
parmesan from the carpet
it's like the media would be destroying
him destroying the family trying to
somehow say
that this has compromised the president
of the united states and it's a national
security issue and the rest of it but
with hunter biden no he can go on
blackface jimmy kimmel show
and it's a reclamation project so again
it's one of those stories that i'm
really only covering
not because of the nitty-gritty or any
kind of holier-than-thou thing or to
mock people with drug problems or
whatever but the point is that they
treat things very differently and and
that was a serious
gaslight move by jimmy kimmel there like
making it about
don jr when we know god damn well what
they would do if this was done junior
let's not forget
that a couple years ago don jr had a
10-minute lunch meeting with someone on
the upper east side and people thought
that meant that
the russians were in charge of the
united states government so it's just
nuts but i also want to address one
thing because it was my uh
it was my producer michael's birthday
last night and i took the whole reuben
report
team out to dinner we all went out to
dinner last night and a photograph
was taken of me and it was leaked okay
it was leaked online
and we went out to boa in in west
hollywood it's my favorite restaurant in
l.a
it was the first time i was at an indoor
restaurant in l.a in over
a year almost a year and a half
basically at this point
um and they've got some great steaks
there i took glenn beck there once he
said it was the best steak he ever had
uh but in any event this this picture
was leaked of me at dinner
last night and uh so i just want to
address it look i just want to address
it yes
there was a little extra thing of
parmesan on the table
and i grabbed that big straw that was
well it was actually a candle it was
like a big
special candle that was in michael's
birthday cake that we got him
and i grabbed the candle and i hollowed
it out and i snorted
all of the parmesan so like look it is
what it is um
my my agents at caa and my publicist
are looking into getting me on the tour
so i'm hoping that i can be on jimmy
kimmel
to talk about my problems tomorrow and
then you know maybe i can get on colbert
or that other guy that nobody watches or
whatever it is you know i'm not perfect
like the parmesan was there i knew i
shouldn't do it i like
i like that pungent cheese i like it and
i'm gonna work through this stuff
and uh yeah i think you see my point let
me show you one other thing related to
all this because as i'm saying this is
really about the media reaction to it
it's not about the parmesan and it's not
about the teeth and it's not even about
hunter biden really this is about how
the media treats things so
a gallup poll came out in the last
couple days uh
talking about who trusts the media so
this is really really interesting
so 75 oh sorry 73
of the democrats have trust in the media
so this is
mass media uh from a great deal to a
fair amount
from 97 to 2020. so over a 23 year
period 73 percent
of the democrats say they trust the
mainstream media you think that has
something to do with the fact that
they're always being nice
to the democrats you think it might have
a little something to do with that
on the republican side only 10 percent
one out of 10 republicans trust the
mainstream media and frankly if you're
one of those
10 people you're a little confused
because they're really just awful that
number is too high
and 36 of independents trust the
mainstream media i mean this is a pretty
extensive poll done by gallup which is
as far as i know still a reputable
organization reputable polling
organization
but that disparity that basically if
we're to say that the country is sort of
50 50 we know how our
national elections go i don't want to
say anything about the election and get
my youtube channel deleted
but basically you know we're a 50 50
country something like that
well if 73 of that one of those halves
says oh yeah all that info we're getting
from the mainstream media that's legit
and only 10 from the other half do well
then bang we're right back
where i always bring everything to which
is that war on reality and that war on
truth and how do
we build a bridge over that chasm as i
called it yesterday that
is the tough part i mean i don't think
at this point if you saw
what we covered earlier in the week with
the the 60 minutes hit piece
on ron desantis which was a completely
fabricated story if you see that
you see the washington post you guys
know this retracting
their story from a couple months ago
about donald trump pressuring
the secretary of state of georgia to
find votes and then it turns out not to
be
true and it's like did anyone get fired
at 60 minutes did anyone get fired at
the washington post no they
they issue retractions or they don't
issue your attractions and nothing ever
changes
so if uh you're perhaps married to or
live with someone or dating someone or
friends with someone or family members
with someone
who is one of those 73 percent you got
some work to do man
and i think it's best done over whiskey
because uh it ain't easy
to un-brainwash these people uh all
right let's move on uh there's a really
interesting story here
so just in the last couple days it's
coming out that we are going to allow
at least at some facilities we are going
to allow biological men
who identify as trans to go to female
prisons now i think you can see why this
is probably not the best idea
i will do the disclaimer one more time
although i'm going to really stop doing
this because i don't like doing it and i
think it goes without saying at this
point
if you as an adult would like to
identify any which way
that is completely fine with me now
we're talking about criminals here so
let's
remove their criminal activity for the
moment but as an adult if you wish to
live
as the opposite gender if that's how you
feel deeply and you want to dress that
way and live that life and be called
that name
i'll treat you completely with respect
and the pronouns that you wish as long
as
you treat me with respect respect is a
two-way street and we are good to go so
this has absolutely nothing to do
with being anti-trans i think what
you're going to see
is that this story has far more to do
with these activists being anti-female
so we've got some numbers
here from the daily caller since january
261 california prison inmates
have requested transfers to prisons
aligning
with their gender identity just to be
clear what that means
is 261 biological men want to be in a
female prison why would they
why would that be dave democratic
governor gavin newsom signed sb 132 into
law in january a bill that requires
the california department of corrections
and rehabilitation to ask
every individual entering the
department's custody
to specify their pronouns their gender
identity
and whether they identify as transgender
non-binary or intersex
the vast majority of these requests were
from inmates requesting to be
transferred
to female facilities and only six
inmates did not request
to be in a women's facility do you see
how silly and ridiculous this is the
fact that we even talk about these trans
issues as much as we do is completely
completely ridiculous in many ways it
shows you that the woke activists
have won right they've won because they
they've set the table of the things that
we have to talk about but a story like
this
needs to be talked about because it's
showing you how deeply corrupt
and and silly these are silly people a
guy like to be recalled gavin newsom
here
in california imagine you're you
murdered a whole family you murdered a
whole bunch of people you shot up a
whole place
you get they bring it into prison oh hi
everybody hi sir
um are you are you a male or female and
what what pronouns could we call sure
you killed all those people but are you
a he or a she or a decepticon or an
autobot
please let me know it's complete
nonsense but
even putting that aside the the the
pronoun part of it
putting the pronoun part of it aside do
you want
people who are criminals potentially
violent criminals i doubt we're talking
a lot about a lot of white-collar
criminals here
do you want rapists and murderers and
people
who are in jail for all sorts of bad
things which is what usually
gets people put in jail in the first
place do you want them being
transferred to a women's prison i
watched orange is the new black
on netflix about a women's prison the
women are doing some pretty scary stuff
by the way so there might be some guys
that get there and be like yo yo put me
back with the
with the with the men because these
chicks are bananas um
so that's possible too may not work out
that well for these 200
you know 80 some odd uh you know trans
biological men going into the women's
facilities
uh but if if any of this is coming as a
surprise to you or if you're
for if you're one of the good liberals
left one of the eight good liberals left
who voted for joe biden because donald
trump is orange
and you're shocked at how far the
administration
is going on all this stuff now i get
this is coming from california governor
newsome but if you're shocked
at how far the democrats have gone well
here we're going to show you a clip
from before the election when joe biden
promised to do just this
yes and by the way in prison in prison
the determination should be that your
sexual
identity is defined by what you say it
is not
what in fact the prison says it is and
in that case you should be entitled
also to ogbyn anyway
uh you didn't ask that question but
you're not likely to either i guess
okay so he had one of his usual mental
breakdowns there but you can see that
they were saying this is what we are
going to do it's not going to be the
gender that's on your birth certificate
or that the
the prison says that you are the one
that you actually biologically are it's
whatever you tell them
that you are and then accordingly we
will put you in that jail
this is not a serious country or or a
serious rule these are ridiculous
people that we are governed by
absolutely ridiculous people
and i don't even think anyone believes
this is right
i believe that there is a tiny sliver of
activists that believe this stuff is
right but that's it and for some reason
you watching this and almost everyone is
afraid of saying what the
god honest obvious truth here is which
is that we shouldn't be mixing these
things and we know that there's going to
be more violence
and congratulations when a guy who gets
put in jail for raping women
says you know what i'd what would be
pretty great if i was in jail wouldn't
it be pretty nice to have a cellmate
who's a chick
and then rapes her while saying that
he's a trans woman and guess what when
that happens
it's on joe biden's head but fortunately
for biden you don't even know what he's
talking about so
i guess he'll he'll be okay with it all
right let's move on so
uh the cdc speaking of non-serious
organizations the center
for disease control has now
declared racism serious
public health threat this is a quote
from cdc director rochelle wallensky you
may remember her from a story we did a
couple days ago that we'll get back to
in just a moment
the pandemic illuminated inequities that
have existed for generations
and revealed for all of america a known
but often unaddressed epidemic impacting
public health
racism it is not just the discrimination
against one group based on the color of
their skin or their race or ethnicity
but the structural barriers that impact
racial and ethnic groups differently
to influence where a person lives where
they work
where their children play and where they
worship and gather in
community and here's a tweet from the
cdc
the covet 19 pandemic has illuminated
long-standing racial and
ethnic health inequities that have
persisted in this country for centuries
learn more about how cdc is working to
understand and measure
the health impacts of racism
okay now look there's there's so much
here what the cdc has now decided to do
the cdc which is supposed to be in
charge of our health and tell us when we
can leave our house
and who we can see and when we can see
them and if we have to wear a mask and a
pair of goggles and all of that nonsense
they've decided to go from being a
health
organization the center for disease
control
which should be worried about diseases
and how to control and contain them
they have now flat out said we are woke
we
are political and in my estimation that
basically means i don't know how i can
trust them they now have decided peter
bogosian
my friend who's been on the show many
times who's assistant professor of
philosophy up at portland state
university and one of the great
scholars fighting woke-ism he often
talks about this
once an organization allows woke-ism in
once you start looking at racial quotas
and how many people
of this color or gender or whatever we
should hire for this or that you've
taken
your eye off the ball of the of the real
goal and what would the real goal
of a regular company be what would the
real goal
of burger king be it would be to sell
burgers they would like to make burgers
at a profit
so that they can make money and also
have happy customers and that keeps
going and then they can keep growing
well what would be the goal of the
center for disease control
would it be to stop racism which is not
something that can actually be stopped
unless you want to kill a lot of people
right i always talk about
the thanos snap right it's like they're
gonna have to kill a lot of people if
they want to kill
something that is inherent to humanity
you don't want people to be racist you
want to fight
the ideas of racism but of course it's
the woksters who are importing
racism who talks about racism endlessly
who wants racial quotas
who's stopping asians from going to
harvard etc
etc it's these very people but once the
center for disease control says okay our
main mission
has now gone from you know covering
and illuminating and discovering ways to
stop diseases
to oh now we've got to stop racism an
amorphous thing that actually can't be
stopped
you're a political organization
congratulations and now the irony is of
course they've been infected by a virus
the cdc has been infected by a mind
virus which is
wokism and it will most likely destroy
the cdc the way it's destroyed most
of our liberal institutions and they
seem to have
no way of stopping it they seem to have
no inoculation they seem to have no
vaccine
and they'll get what they get uh and
then i just thought this was interesting
i think this came originally from larry
elder my buddy larry elder on twitter
if you want to just talk about racism
and sort of where we're at with racism
because we always bring this down to
police killing people right
so according to weather.com lightning
kills an average of 49 people each year
in the united states lightning kills an
average of 49 people
each year in the united states get that
in your head for a moment and now from
politifact
police in the line of duty fatally shot
unarmed black people and 20 unarmed
white people in 2019 so in 2019
police shot 10 unarmed black people
fatally 49 people uh died
of a lightning strike now i can we can
talk all about police brutality we can
talk about all those things i'm just
trying to juxtapose some silly stuff
here
in a way and that's what larry's point
was originally when he tweeted that out
let's also remember the united states
and i know i'm going to get some haters
for this one but i'm ready
the united states is the least racist
society
in the history of the world our founding
was based
on bringing all sorts of people from all
sorts of walks of life
the poor and the huddled masses to come
here and have a shot at that pursuit of
happiness
to have equality and have a chance at
making a better life and almost
everyone in the united states in our
250-year history
has it better than their parents did and
way better than their grandparents and
way better before that and that doesn't
matter
whether you're black or white or latino
or gay or trans or a unicorn or whatever
it might be
you've got a chance for equality here
and they're trying to change it to
equity and it's deeply deeply dangerous
but you know the cdc it's very obvious
that these people have been losing their
minds for quite some time
here's that same cdc director we played
this last week i think uh
who's you know these are the people that
are supposed to be calming us down right
if we had a if we had a crazy pandemic
raging through the world right now
raging through the united states which
by the way i was talking to some friends
last night
at dinner it was at the parmesan
snorting dinner and i was saying
doesn't this seem odd that how is not
one country fallen
because of kovid like we're all every
country is doing different things every
state in this case in the united states
is doing different things
but why is one country that maybe
doesn't have
the best way of getting information
across or the best systems in place to
take care of their people
just like completely fallen or their
numbers are like 20 times higher than
other places
like why hasn't that happened in nigeria
for example or just
pick any country whatever you want like
it just hasn't happened but okay let's
put that aside for a second i was
snorting parmesan
you have this crazy pandemic and the
head of the cdc you think she'd be
calming people down
but here she is last week now is one of
those times when i have to share the
truth
and i have to hope and trust you will
listen
i'm going to pause here i'm going to
lose the script
and i'm going to reflect on the
recurring feeling i have of impending
view
that's right she's going to pause here
and lose the script as she keeps looking
down and reading the script
oh lady lady lady lady it's all it's all
theater you know
i've been thinking lately we're sort of
in like the show must go on version of
democracy at this point
where none of the stuff is working like
the machine is not working
we didn't even cover the story how right
now biden has
uh put together a task force to look
into expanding the supreme court i mean
i'm telling you guys
they are here to destroy everything and
we're running out of time
but i don't like depressing you so that
we still got a chance that's the point
that's the point we still got a chance
but man it's like she's
you know on one hand telling us the
impending dooms coming we've got to stop
racism oh god these people are clowns
live your life
love people go out for food have sex if
you wanna hang with hunter biden
you know it's better than listening to
these dingbats all right i want to do
one more
uh marriott hotels they are testing
replacing their
desk clerks with automated kiosks and of
course that should surprise
nobody because the more that the
government meddles in what
private companies are supposed to do
when it comes to paying their employees
the more that private companies will do
what they're supposed to do
which is innovate and find better ways
to be more profitable
this is from the new york post the
world's biggest hotel chain said it's
testing
automated kiosks equipped with touch
screens that can check in guests
and spit out room keys as well as giant
vending machines it calls grab
and go marketplaces that can dispense
everything from
coffee to breakfast sandwiches and
cereal
marriott said the so-called contactless
arrival kiosks
are meant to ease customers fears about
getting covet 19 by interacting
with hotel staff marriott said 65
percent of travelers say they wanted
the latest technologies to make them
feel safe and that 87
of us customers say they would like to
see companies continue
to offer options that limit in-person
service i want to say something broadly
about this
this strikes me as deeply dangerous now
nothing in there nowhere in there did
marriott say oh we're doing this because
we don't want to pay employees
but they're not just doing it for the
health and the security of you okay
they're looking at bottom lines and
going how okay
we don't have to pay these people as
much we can just replace them i mean we
can just literally replace them
with computers we can turn on skynet and
arnold schwarzenegger is going to have
to
you know attack the liquid terminator
okay that's sort of where we're at with
things but i want to say something about
that last line there
because they want to continue to offer
options that limit in-person service so
as i said earlier
last night was the first night that i've
been out to an indoor restaurant in
about a year and a half i've only been
out
in la maybe twice at outdoor restaurants
and then i've been to dallas
and florida which are wonderful and
functional places and i love you and i
want to be in you
but
but being out last night in l.a we had a
great time and again
michael's birthday's today so wish him a
happy birthday in the comment section um
but i have to say that being out and
this restaurant that i mentioned is my
favorite steak joint in l.a it's like
just the right amount of
la like a little bit of celebrity it's
kind of modern and cool the food's great
staff is great there's a couple waiters
there who are fans of mine so we always
just have a great old time
actually that picture that you make you
guys may remember that went really viral
of when the whole idw crew
me and rogan and shapiro and weinstein
and peterson we all were having dinner
it was at this place boa
but we went there last night and you
know they have the tables separated
nobody can sit at the bar everyone's
walking around with a mask inside
i'm not saying anything about mass i
don't even want to make this about covid
but i do want to make this
about that last line that i just read
which is that they're going to continue
to offer options that limit in-person
service
there's something that we're doing right
now that is breaking down
human bonds we are not supposed to just
see each other behind plexiglass with
masks
you know it was like there was nobody
sometimes when i go to a restaurant i
actually do this often if i'm meeting a
friend for dinner
i'll usually get there a little bit
early and sit at the bar and then i just
strike up a conversation with someone
that's what i used to like to do
like there was some like level of human
interaction and we are breaking
that down we are actually breaking that
down if you can't sit at bars you know
this place used to be packed all the
time and it was sort of a who's who and
an interesting
set of people would be there and it just
we had a great time the food was great
again happy birthday michael
hope you enjoyed that uh you like that
feta what was that that was the goat
cheese
filo dough uh balakava
baklava not the balacava that was funny
a little call back to an episode about
two months ago
so we had a great time but it was just
like this thing where you're not sitting
near anybody
and the waiter the waiter's got a face
shield and a mask and you can't really
hear him and he's telling you the
he's telling you the specials that what
what now like everyone will start acting
like 87 years
sir can you repeat that you've got the
steak now what now how do you cook that
with the who
anyway we got to get past some of this
stuff guys we got to figure out a way to
be a human
again which is why i'm actually having
lunch with a friend in just a little bit
anyway i hope you enjoyed the show today
i i thoroughly enjoyed the show today
but i am looking forward to the weekend
we're just going to chill out relax
over here probably eat some food and if
you want to see what we're eating and
what we're drinking and what i'm
listening to and all that good stuff
you can go to reubenreport.locals.com
part three of my interview with samuel
rodriguez which is a really interesting
interview about faith
and about immigration this is he's a
pastor here in california who's worked
for three administrations worked for gw
bush worked for clinton and worked
for trump uh if you i'm sorry no he
didn't work for clinton he worked for
george w bush he worked for obama
and trump so the really interesting
pedigree right there uh
we uh we just put up part three of that
and of course the full thing is up ad
free reubenreport.locals.com that's it
for me
i've got my iced coffee here my parmesan
over there and i'll see you on monday
you